hey guys in this video we're going to
talk about how to fix hunchback okay you
know the person that has this like
Buffalo Hump back here now let me
differentiate now you actually have a
fat pad in the back I'm not really
talking about the fat pad I'm talking
about really severe poor posture and
we're going to show you the best way to
do with that but the first thing to know
is there's a vertebra called c7 and it's
the seventh vertebra in your neck it's
at the bottom part and what you have to
know is that that one is normally
sticking out a little bit more than the
rest so if you think that's abnormal
it's not everyone has a very large c7
vertebra okay
so want to point that out also if you
have a lipoma that is a fatty tumor
sometimes that could be on your back
creating a little hunchback in which
case you may want to get to surgically
removed because it's really difficult to
get rid of that okay but I'm talking
about the person with really bad posture
and what happens is that when you're
slouched like this on the inside of your
spine
there is a ligament and there are
muscles that are too tight and they're
pulling you forward all the chest
muscles are too tight and they're
pulling you forward so when your parents
would tell you to sit up straight
that was actually bad advice because
every time you would stretch this all
you're doing is you're stretching that
rubber band and it's going to come right
back okay well your parents should have
told you is to do the opposite okay so
in this next part I'm going to show you
the best stretch for reversing this
hunchback and I want you to do it right
now as you're sitting there and then put
your comments below because it's pretty
cool okay the first thing to not do is
sit up tall stretch backwards we don't
want to do that because all the
tightness is on the front part of the
body or the inside of the spine on the
front part so what we want to do is you
want to stretch the back part which will
send electrical signals to the front to
relax it and just kind of demonstrate
this so tuck your heads forward as much
as you can now slouch you upper back all
the way down yeah that's right all the
way down yeah
is exactly what your the opposite of
what your parents told you to do right
you said sit up tall no you actually
tell the child to slouch more so okay
let's do it again Tucker its forward all
the way and we're actually hunched your
back we're trying to make her back more
hunched its hunches you can get it and
it's actually going to stretch all this
and relax all that tightness on the
front part and it's every time she does
this she's going to come up more and
more and more and you're probably not
going to believe me until you do this on
yourself I'm going to do it like five to
ten times do the Sykes's once a day
slouch all the way down yeah that's
right good you're going to hold that
stretch
good come back up and what you're going
to notice it's easier to come up more
and more and more and so I'm not saying
you can't stretch back but this is the
key move to allow you to bring you out
of that hunchback state all right go
ahead and try this and put your comments
below